we are talking about a harm formal
definitions of harm it's obviously
related to AI systems even though the
concept of harm has been around
for a very long time you think of
Hippocratic Oaths that the doctors still
take to this day in particular it says I
Will Do no harm right to my patients
so the philosophers had this concept in
front of them and they wanted to Define
it for for a long time and they
essentially gave up on it so there is a
paper from as recent as 2012. it's quite
recent and philosophy right and computer
science it would be the dinosaur area
2012 it's just not not relevant anymore
but in philosophy it's practically
yesterday
so it's paper by broadly prominent
philosopher who says harm is a from
Christian jumble we don't know what to
do with it we should just do away with
harm and replace it by other more
well-behaved Notions
right but ignoring it doesn't make it go
away unfortunately right and also now
also for example we are facing an
imminent I think
rise of autonomous cars on the road so
who is exactly going to be in short and
against what
so it's very difficult very difficult
question so we really have to urgently
Define harm and and to quantify harm to
Define who is harming whom so when we
have the characters driven by
a person
Pluto then it's easy right so Pluto is
careless and there is an accident with
another car Pluto was driving so his
insurance company has to has to pay to
the injured one but let's imagine that
there are two autonomous cars now this
car there's a person inside in this car
there's also a person inside but they're
not driving there's almost cars are
driving and let's now imagine so we
they're driving on the road and there is
a safety fence right this one on the
border of the road
so so this autonomous car is driving Bob
Bob is actually completely
um distracted watching the previous
computer file video quite a while ago
now I did a video on it and then the
stationary car can be there for multiple
reasons that may be broken down out of
charge Etc so now it has uh three
options one of them is to alert Bob who
he is distracted by the fascinating
computer file video another one to do
nothing to just crash into the
stationary car right and this will be
terrible so Bob will die and the person
inside the stationary car will die as
well and so it is to crash into the
safety fence which means that Bob will
be mildly injured based on the current
proposition of how to deal with people
who sit inside autonomous cars they are
not going to be considered drivers or
responsible for any behavior of
autonomous cars because how could they
they are completely distracted by the
computer of all videos they're not even
looking at their own the car is not
going to suddenly seizing control and
somehow alerting the crash so the car
chooses the option of crashing into the
safety fence so Bob is mild injured and
now Bob wants to sue the manufacturers
of the autonomous car or the software
company who provide the provided the
algorithms
um saying well I didn't expect that
right I was injured
um you you wronged me
um and the car manufacturers say well
actually this was the best possible
outcome
so how can we formalize all this story
and to get something to get to some
conclusion
so first of all we are
putting all this discussion in the
framework of causality
of course so first of all we would say
that a harmed B if in particular the
action of a is somehow caused the result
because I mean it in a very broad sense
so it is well defined but we're not
going into this formal definitions it
had some influence on the outcome right
it's not completely relevant it's not
the fact that that the current latest uh
snowing in Siberia right so it's it is
actually relevant to the current
situation
um
so okay so that's one two
um there is another thing that the uh
that a or you know in this case the car
could have done
that would would have avoided
um the this outcome right it would have
caused the another outcome maybe it's
not a deal but it's another outcome and
this outcome would have been better
um and but they caused I mean that maybe
some other things should have changed as
well but we can imagine a very similar
scenario which is slightly different in
which the car makes a different decision
and it is a better outcome for Bob
uh now what we add to this so this up up
to now it's more or less standard
definition of causality we have two
things first is the utility function
which actually quantifies how much harm
was done
so in this case we can quantify the harm
that was done to Bob injuring him and
contrasted with harm that could have
been done to Bob he's had the car
crashed into the stationary car and that
Bob would have been dead right so this
is a maximal harm I guess that you can
cause uh to Bob
um versus the utility of not harming
bulb at all which is what what he
expected so that's one
ah and two is the default value
so why do I need the default value we
need the default value the default value
is somehow the lowest possible utility
which is yet still not harm
for that imagine the case with a
birthday present right so you invite a
friend over to a birthday party friend
comes over
um and brings you a 10 pound 10 pounds
bottle of wine
you're kind of a bit disappointed
because you expected a fabulous present
in fact you've been hinting to your
friend that you expect this amazing
Brandy 40 years Brandy that you saw in
the shop for 200 pounds but you have no
idea anyway 200 pounds so yeah you are
disappointed right but you wouldn't say
that your friend harmed you I mean it's
still above the default your friend
could have come empty-handed
so okay so we have the default right
which is kind of the threshold which is
below the default is harm what is above
the default is no term so you're not
expressly happy but you cannot say that
your friend harmed you in this situation
remember the autonomous car chose to to
crash into the safety fence so first of
all what is the default
so Bob is saying the default is that I
expected to get to where I'm going to my
destination
um healthy right I left healthy I
expected to get healthy what is this
enjoy
um okay so first of all we can
you know we can accept it
now second of all uh if we talk about
default and utility we have to check
whether this default is achievable
whether they actually exist something
that the car could have done
uh with slight modifications of possible
values of other factors
that would have resulted in a better
outcome
so in this particular case the the
default right because he wants to to
arrive on harm and let's say that we are
not thinking about the case where the
Bob's car would have driven straight
towards the stationary car and then the
stationary car teleported somewhere else
and then continue driving this is not
possible we're not considering this
we're not considering Bob's car suddenly
becoming a Batmobile but mobile and
flying over no I mean we are reasonable
people we are considering reasonable
changes
so okay so in this case I think we can
safely say that the default was
unachievable and actually any other
possible outcome so another possible
outcome would have been to do nothing to
continue driving in the Lord Bob or to
crash into the current front
um and effectively both of them would
have resulted in a crush and popping
that so there is nothing that the car
would have done
um to make this station better for Bob
right so this whole discussion leads to
um the decision that Bob was actually
not harmed by the decision of the car
right so that's the concept of harm now
in order to actually decide how much of
the insurance premium the company is
going to pay uh we need to be able to
quantify our so far we hadn't Quantified
anything we just decided that the car
didn't harm Bob right according to these
assumptions into this defaults right
let's imagine
Alice
yeah that's just looking well it's not
going to a restaurant and having a meal
and then this is Alice waiter that's
also a table not looking very happy
you'll see why so Alice had a nice meal
and she got a bill of a hundred dollars
right so let's say we're there in the US
hundred dollars as we all know us is a
tipping country
so now the even I think they put options
for tip underneath so tips so it will be
like 20 is this written 25 is
that's a kind of pre-calculate the tip
assuming that you will keep 20 at least
so
um next the waiter expects the tip of 20
which is going to be oops
twenty dollars
okay the problem is that the restaurant
only accepts tips in cash
and Alice didn't go by the ATM this
morning or there was no ATM on the way
to the restaurant she only has five
dollars cash in her wallet
and she paid the the bill with the
credit card okay so she gives the way to
the whole five dollars the waiter is
very unhappy as we can see but can we
claim that Alice harmed the waiter
actually
well first of all it depends on the
default I think we can again agree that
default would be twenty dollars
because the waiter has no idea right I
have to know this because I'm going to
America soon so it's very important very
important yes
when 20 is expected unfortunately yes
waiter expects twenty dollars
now is it achievable if we say well it's
not achievable because Alice only has
five dollars what what is he gonna do
give her watch and the earrings there's
nothing she can do and then we'll say
well twenty dollars is unachievable the
maximum that's achievable is five and
she gave five dollars so therefore
there's no harm
she's gonna have to go out to the ATM
get some money out come back and give it
to the waiter yes exactly so another way
to look at it is to say no twenty
dollars is entirely achievable she
should say to the waiter
um I'm leaving my coat and my bag here
I'll be right back go out to the ATM
withdraw the money and come back and
leave twenty dollars so if to if it's
achievable then she actually should have
given him twenty dollars and therefore
she haunt him at fifty dollars right it
would take utility the same as um as the
dollar amount
okay so so this is the Dilemma of a
chewable versus not a chewable
um and by the way what happens if Alice
decides that she needs to keep some
money in her wallet she doesn't want to
update completely and gives the waiter
one dollar tip
so in this case I think we can agree
that she harmed the waiter regardless of
whether ATM is close by or not
um but the amount of harm is different
so if we say that the maximum that's
achievable is five dollars
than to have the weighted four dollars
right five minus one if we say that the
default is achievable then of course you
have the waiter at 19 because that's
going to be 20 minus one why is harm
better than utility or more interested
is just utility because here I think
what we've done is more or less we
subtracted utilities
right
um so let's talk about
um a doctor doctor's dilemma so we have
a patient let's take another
I think this one is
looking sufficiently miserable
so this is a patient and this is a
doctor
right so the patient is ill
and the doctor has a dilemma of whether
to to give the patient medication or to
do a surgery okay so medication will
keep the patient stable let's say that
if the patient is healthy that's going
to be utility one right which is the
best if the patient is ill but not dead
it's going to be half
and that is going to be zero so
medication will keep the patient stable
at 0.5 surgery will cure the patient
completely
except sometimes it it fails right well
no sometimes surgeries don't end well
maybe the patient is allergic to
Anesthesia
where you say
um possible causes that are not not um
under the doctor's control okay so it
will cure the patient or
it will kill the patient with some small
probability p
I don't think we're all used to it if we
are going to the hospital for even some
minor procedure we always have to sign a
consent form that says there is small
probability of
um
etc etc and then some horrible things
that could happen and let's say that P
is small
so what is the expected utility for
medication from the surgery let's say
that the physician is only basing their
decision on on utility
so medication always guaranteed results
0.5 right so the expectation so here is
0.5 that's that's the result of opening
steering medication for the short term
the result is 1 minus P it's a 1 minus p
is the probability of the successful
surgery okay so it's multiplied by one
plus P multiplied by zero so it's one
minus B
so the expected to take is 1 minus P now
if p is small as we assumed as it
usually happens with surges otherwise it
wouldn't be and they're going than ever
then of course surgery wins right one
minus p is bigger than 0.5 right but
that's utility but let's now tokens in
terms of harm so the patient has been
ill for a while they're kind of used to
this
unpleasant model unpleasant feeling for
them the default is 0.5 the default is
how they are feeling right now and now
treating them with medication doesn't
result in anything lower than the
default right so it's all going to harm
them just going to stabilize this this
current condition in the contrary the
surgery so with the probability y minus
P it's going to
completely cure them so this is no harm
so this is above harm but with
probability p
it's going to actually result in patient
deaths which has the utility zero which
is 0.5 below
to the default right so now we have the
expected harm from the surgery 0.5 VP
and the expected harmful medication is
zero hmm
so now I will suddenly perform
medication so this is just different
ways of looking at the same thing right
it is different ways of looking at the
same thing yet it solves quite a lot of
um moral dilemmas how does this play
into compute science then so so this uh
is very relevant to AI to AI systems
autonomous systems the adoption of
autonomous systems is not going to
happen unless we figure all this out
uh it's not going to happen unless we
figure out explanations which is
something that I talked about in my
previous video it's not going to happen
until we figure out harm and it's not
going to happen until we figure out
fairness I think so for this particular
subject of harm the insurance companies
are going to block the regulation that
allows the autonomous cars on the road
or rather they will refuse to ensure
that autonomous cars which will block
the manufacturers of the autonomous cars
for blazing them on the road uninsured
until all this is figured out
if we Kill Bill and we give his organs
to those people so five people will be
healthy one person is going to be that
so what happens if I cover this part
this is probably no longer a panda right
this is not about that